[Music]
we are uh 21.65 let's keep going
10 minute game
2238 that is the highest rated player we
faced
e4 let's go with a um let's go with the
cairo
let's go with the caro
let's play something a little bit more
positional
let's go with the caro the narrow con
yeah we've been playing the carol pretty
consistently in the speed run
all right
so this is the pawn of attack
this is
probably top three in terms of most
popular weapons against the karo khan if
you play the caro
you have to know
what to do against the pawn of this is
one of the most reputable and one of the
most dangerous lines in existence so you
start by playing knight f6
and the
pawn structure that is most closely
associated with the pawn up is what who
can tell me what is the
pawn structure
type
that yeah iqp so pano and ib are not
synonyms the iqp just means isolated
queen pawn and if at any moment white
takes on d5 or black takes on c4 the d4
pawn becomes isolated you get a classic
iqp pawn structure so for now we're
developing our pieces knight c6 now
white has two main moves there's knight
f3 which is the traditional line the
other move is bishop g5 so
traditionally
the main move here is bishop g4 that
leads to a forcing line which results in
an equal end game
and in terms of playing for a win bishop
g4 is sub-optimal there is also the more
conservative option of playing e6
nothing wrong with that well it's a
little bit passive but it leads to an
iqp structure but
recently there also has been a very
interesting line that i have seen
in the database at first i could not
believe my eyes because it looks like an
insane move but we're actually going to
try it and see how it lands against a
strong player and that is the move not
pawn e6 but bishop e6
now the reason that this move should
cause revulsion in u is because
it blocks the bishop on f8 but
the bishop on f8 can be developed in two
other ways the first
okay white plays bishop g5 so if white
takes our knight then we will take with
the e pawn and our bishop will then have
a diagonal we're happy we're groovy so
against bishop g5 the theory is to play
queen to a5
we develop our queen to a nice spot
bishop f6 there we go e takes f6 now i'm
not aware that this is already i think
we're out of theory and i think our
opponent is bluffing us c5 okay
now this is one of the main ideas for
white to play c5 so here's the thing
how do we handle this position with
black
now what we need to try to do here is
attack the d4 pawn this is going to be
the biggest really the only target in
white's position the way that we're
going to do it is as follows we're going
to play
we're going to fianchetto our bishop
then
if
we are permitted we're going to put the
bishop on g4 we're going to try to trade
the bishop for the knight on f3 and
eventually we're going to open up the
diagonal with f5 now we're probably not
going to be permitted to play all of
these moves
but we're going to do our best to play
as many of them as we can let's start
with g6
let's develop our bishop to g7 castles
castles this is all
we can all we can execute this very
quickly castles castles and now we are
more or less ready to play bishop g4 the
only problem is that d5 is going to hang
so we'll need to calculate it carefully
okay a3
so let's consider first and foremost the
move bishop g4 does bishop g4 work here
so what happens bishop g4
knight takes d5
we can just play knight takes d4 yeah it
works pretty handily i think we can
safely go bishop g4 that was not hard to
calculate
and i think that we are able to achieve
our ideal setup b4 is not dangerous
though we can just drop our queen back
to d8 and in a way that actually helps
us because now the pawn on d5 is
protected by the queen bishop e2 and
what is the completion move of our plan
what is the final move
what is the final move of our plan
yeah now we play the move f5 we open up
the dark square bishop and our plan has
worked to perfection
okay rook b1
now very important here is not to rush
with bishop takes f3 that is a move we
can play a little bit later the problem
with bishop takes f3 straight away and
our opponent has just made an incredibly
strong move by the way
is that after bishop takes f3 knight
takes d4 white can snap up the pawn on
d5 so ideally
ideally we would make a move
that would somehow over protect the pawn
on d5 no such move exists
so in lieu of that
we should make
a move that somehow improves our
position and i'm thinking of two moves
queen d7 looks pretty interesting
rook e8 also looks nice i think these
moves are largely interchangeable we're
going to play queen d7 anyway
and after h3 we can actually consider
going bishop h5 this pawn on f5
also contains the strength of
disallowing g4 queen d2
okay let me think about this for a
second
so again we do not have to rush with
bishop takes f3 that move
is on tap there's not much that black
can
what i can do about it so i think that
we should continue improving our
position but we need to be careful about
how we do that we play queen d7 here
white actually has the move b5 which is
very very annoying
because after queen d7 b5 if we take on
f3 white has bc attacking our queen
so actually queen d7 is not as good
we have an exchange sacrifice rookie 4
is very interesting as well
don't like it as much i think it's
dubious
we could play a6 and try to prevent b5
yes for sure
we could play a6
i like that move let's play a6 let's
prevent b5
of course a4 uh yeah rook takes c2 is
interesting too but i i
don't think the comp is sufficient there
okay rookie e1
now i think
now i think we should play queen d7
now i think we should play queen d7
so we're just improving our position
kind of a cat and mouse game bishop d1
very good move by our opponent
this guy's very serious
rookie four is very interesting here
but i'm not enthralled by that either
let's go rook 88 and bring our other
rook into the game
maybe rookie 6 was
stronger he goes king h1
i mean even here rookie 4 again looks
very interesting
rook takes c1 rook takes c1 there there
there there there
calculation calculation i think rookie 6
makes sense
now the purpose of the move rookie 6 is
twofold the first is we are tempting
light into taking on e6
and here we're gonna go bishop h5 we are
not going to take on f3 just yet g3 okay
this has to be bad
now the second purpose of the move
rookie six
aha wait a second take sticks there are
some tactics there oh
oh i think i see something sexy
i think i i think the time has come for
us to take
i think the time has come for us to take
and i'll
if our opponent falls for
the concept i will retroactively show
you how i found it what we are hoping
for is bishop takes d5 but as a 2200
the guy sees it sadly he sees it there
was a a very nice trap there bishop
takes d5 we had knight f3
but that idea simply exists as a
standalone idea so we can make an
improving move here without worrying
about bishop takes d5
so what catches my eye is a couple of
things rookie four is very interesting
sacking the exchange
um and getting a major pawn phalanx
what else catches maya yeah rookie 4
looks very interesting
i actually really like it um
let me think
i don't see too many other moves
unfortunately amazingly he's somehow
holding on
queen c6 maybe
but then queen eight two
yeah rookie four looks like the way to
go
i'm gonna have to accelerate my pace
here
because i've got three minutes and i'm
gonna have to do a little bit less
talking
and a little bit more playing
because the guy is incredibly good
let's go f5 solidify
let's go bishop e5 solidify
no i'm not i'm i'm not too sussed about
my opponent
the pace is weird but i'm i'm
okay if he if he continues to outplay me
i will definitely be sus now but i think
i'm doing quite okay actually
i'm on guard
just so everybody i'm on guard because
the guy is definitely out out out
thinking me i've also been doing a lot
of talking so
i'm certainly not suspicious yet at all
the pace the pace is the only thing
about his play right now that is weird
okay when a2 but now i check him now
ah we're checking h2
bring the queen in
very strange play queen b3
let's go h5
but now f4 now
am i not just crushing him
what is this
oh he takes on a four goes queen g3
okay i think
but bishop h3
what
okay really riley
really riley
okay i think i now i know where this
game is going
king g2 queen e6 rook d4
okay obviously this is a blatant cheater
this is like he's not even trying to
hide i mean four seconds every move rook
takes d4 four seconds
watch this four seconds then take stage
three
that's hilarious
what rook f7
f7
oh my god
okay obviously
now
here's gonna be the funny thing he's
gonna take on d5
i'm gonna make a knight and he's gonna
move his watch him move his king he's
gonna go king g2 after four seconds
no he takes it wow
has he stopped
oh i had a good game until bishop h3
i guess i was just disconcerted because
i i knew he was
i could sense that he was cheating
at that point
yeah
that's sad
okay we're obviously gonna report him
i was better like he was clearly not
cheating
up to a point
he was clearly not cheating up to a
point and then he started when he was
worse he started
yeah you can definitely sense the moment
when he started
h4 and a4 were both top moves
yeah rook f7 is the second move
no but the accuracy is going to be low
he did not cheat the first 24 25 moves
and then he turned it on at some point
because that was better
he played very poorly the first 84.5
because he played poorly the first stage
of the game
but i don't even feel like analyzing
this is this is disgusting
this is honestly disgusting so
yeah he's won all of his games
he's won all of his games
so unless this is magnus
he's a cheater
no this is [ __ ] i mean it's it's so sad
that people do this
um
all right
all right guys i'm gonna i'm gonna play
a good good one tomorrow
this is just very disheartening
but i will uh i will get a good game in
tomorrow i'll have a little bit more
energy to explain my moves and stuff
we'll maybe play a 15-minute game
tomorrow to really so i really am able
to explain stuff
uh i am going to raid
i'm gonna raid alexandra samaganova or
charlie
i'm gonna write alexander salaganova
um
who forgets a floss thank you thank you
for reminding me
and uh
yeah this guy will get banned
and i will definitely stream tomorrow
thank you have a good start to your
sunday i'll see you guys
tomorrow bye
[Music]